-Welcome back, everybody.
We are here with
Samuel L. Jackson!
Now, come on.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Samuel, you have a career
that spans decades
of both Oscar-winning movies,
some of the most
famous franchises of all time.
You've seen it all.
I thought that you could help me
settle some of
the biggest and most important
debates ever.
Are you ready to do this?
-No fear.
-Alright, It's time for
"Samuel L. Jackson Settles It."
-♪ "Samuel L. Jackson
Settles It" ♪
♪ "Samuel L. Jackson
-There you go, bud.
Alright, here we go.
First up, is it...
-[ Laughs ] "Pee-can" pie
or "pe-cahn"?
Is that what you said?
-"Pe-cahn."
-"Pe-cahn" pie.
-Uh, "pee-can" pie
if you're from the South,
"pe-cahn" pie
if you're from the North.
-Ah! Alright, alright.
"Pe-cahn" pie.
-Real.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You've got to have
that pine smell in the house.
You know, you got to smell it.
You can't smell that
tinsel tree,
that aluminum thing
that people put up.
-I had a fake thing
in my house for years.
My whole life, growing up,
I had the same Christmas tree.
It was in the basement.
and every time we pulled it out,
it's this musty smell,
and that is the smell
of Christmas for me.
-That is so bad. No.
-Alright.
-Homemade stuffing!
Come on. Stove Top? What?!
-What?!
-Really?
-Stove Top stuffing --
I mean, the city dwellers
who never had to cook at home or
never had a real kitchen
or never wanted to smell
the food cooking all day --
See, you've got to have that
smell all day.
You can't just have it Stove Top
quick, quick, quick.
No.
-No. It's got to go all the way.
Alright. Good.
I like the homemade.
Oh, come on.
-On what?
On a plane?
-Yeah.
-Oh, people get choices?
[ Laughter ]
If I'm on a --
Well, I like an aisle seat
because I don't like
crawling over people,
when I used to fly
with other people.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Wow! Wow! You really...
Wow! That's the old
Samuel -- Yeah.
-Well, you have to adjust --
The times, you adjust --
You fix your contract perks
so that you...
-Yeah. Very smart man.
-...don't fly with other people.
-I know.
-Ooh, fries.
-Yeah.
Sautéed onions.
-Oh, really?
-Sautéed onions.
You know...
-That'll spruce 'em up.
-Yeah.
-The original "Star Wars."
-Okay.
-Yeah. I mean,
there's nothing like --
That was the first time --
You know, I remember
watching that film on,
like, 44th Street.
I was, like, at the
second screening or something.
When they go into hyperspace
for the first time,
that was like,
"Oh, my God, what was that?"
-"I've never seen
anything like that."
-Plus, I mean,
that was like during the time
when you had,
like, horrible weed
and you had, like,
little nickel bags.
And you're sitting there
and you're like...
And then they go "Da-da-da"
and they hit it.
-Yeah, yeah.
-Everybody's like, "Whoaaa!"
It was like the bomb.
It was all that. Yeah.
-And, finally, let's figure this
out once and for all.
What is the best curse word?
-The best curse word.
Damn, that's hard to say.
[ Drumroll ]
I mean, I love my favorite
because it's my favorite,
but everybody
doesn't do it great.
And -- I don't know, man.
It's like --
There's so many good ones.
-There's a lot of good ones.
-Yeah.
You know, the ones with
one syllable
aren't as good as the ones
with two and three syllables.
-Yeah, four syllables --
-So if you got --
The more syllables you have,
the better the curse word.
-Like a "enh-enh, enh-enh."
-Mm-hmm.
-"Enh-enh, enh-enh."
-Yeah, right. You know.
-So, we would say --
-Well, you know,
rather than saying --
"Sum'bitch" is not good as
"son of a bitch!"
-Yeah!
-You know?
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
It's all about the syllables.
There you have it.
Samuel L. Jackson.